war is coming
everybody is Charlie so I've got a bunch
of questions about captain marbles
powers how do they work how powerful is
she how powerful she compared to the
other Avengers characters and the other
movies that we've seen so far like Thor
and Thor Ragnarok gladiator Hulk
so we'll do a breakdown to that the
Marvel future fight people gave me some
video that shows off her powers a little
bit better than what you get from the
Captain Marvel movie trailers so I'll
play that in a second many thanks to the
netmarble people for sponsoring this
video - it's always fun to talk about
people's powers if you are new to my
channel I do Marvel videos every week be
sure to subscribe to get everything
but there's a couple of different power
levels that she goes through during the
Captain Marvel movies so careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the movie
yet we'll be talking about very specific
things but here's like a brief clip that
shows off most of her powers that you
see during the movie
that's actually from the new marvel
future fight captain marvel update so if
you're a big fan of that game or you
want to download that I'll put a link in
the description but they gave you some
new skins it's Ronin this young Nick
Fury you get min irva and her new star
force costume and obviously Captain
Marvel but just starting at the
beginning of when Captain Marvel gets
her powers then going through the movie
in a linear fashion because technically
the movie itself isn't linear in the way
they reveal what her backstory is so
just to make it simple we'll start with
when she gets her powers in the accident
and go from there she starts out flying
the experimental jet with Marvel Wendy
Lawson they get shot down by Jude Law's
gone wrong for Marvel and her research
to get the faster-than-light engine
before that happens Carol Danvers is
just a totally normal hundred percent
human pilot who then blows up the
tesseract engine which explodes all the
energy and fuses her however Marvel
leeched energy from the tesseract I
assume it's a very Captain America first
Avengers scenario where Red Skull was
basically just leeching energy out of
the tesseract and just putting it into
weapons using it like Power Cells so I
assume it's a similar situation with
this faster-than-light engine so the
tesseract energy is like the fuel when
it explodes Carol's body absorbs all
that Infinity stone energy which is why
she's crackling with photonic energy and
GaN drugs like hey wait a minute and he
hatches his plan to take her is a very
similar situation to Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver getting their powers from
the mind gem red round when infinity war
was hitting theaters Marvel did a really
cool thing they just kind of clarified
what was going on with scarlet witch's
powers and where they came from because
technically she's a mutant from the
x-men comics but she's also a part of
the Avengers in the MCU
but around infinity war Marvel was
saying that the mind stone only enhanced
what was already there sort of unlocked
latent abilities that she already had so
it's pretty clear that they were
basically saying that she's a mutant but
we can't use that term so we're gonna
call her enhanced and that is what Carol
Danvers is in the MCU she's an enhanced
person but at the moment she absorbs all
that tesseract energy and it modifies
her body she has a hundred percent
potential for every power and special
ability she's ever going to have without
wearing an Infinity Gauntlet or holding
an actual infinity stone yes there's
always ways to take people to 110 or 120
percent of their base power levels but
just at 100
sent regular power levels Captain Marvel
already has all those abilities the
minute she gets her powers
so she's knocked unconscious and this is
when the Kree and the supreme
intelligence make her part Kree like we
all wondered if she was gonna be you
know half QWERTY or if her mother was
gonna secretly be a Kree person the way
they're explaining it during the Captain
Marvel movie is that she's a normal
human she's got all this tesseract
energy jaan raghav the supreme
intelligence want the consolation prize
if they can't have the faster-than-light
engine they want the weapon that
absorbed all that crazy infinity stone
energy so what they do to exploit her is
that they Gaslight the hell out of her
to keep her thinking that she's Kree
they swap her human blood with yon
Raghib Lud he even says during the movie
she has my blood flowing through her
veins so that she'll bleed green blood
and she'll think that she is Kree and
when you scan her she'll biologically
read as a Kree but then very important
they give her that special chip that
dampens her powers and they lie telling
her that they're giving her her powers
her dual iron fists photon style but
they tell her that the chip is the way
that they're giving her at those powers
this is a gift that we're giving to you
and they keep repeating that dialogue
what is given can be taken away and the
supreme intelligence tries to completely
block her powers before she shorts it
out and rips it off when she's wearing
the chip early in the movie in the
supreme intelligence isn't totally
messing with her she just has somewhat
enhanced strength durability like a
really badass soldier and fairly
powerful photonic blast from her fist
but that's it those are her abilities
when she gets rid of the dampener and
they have that scene of her standing up
slowly with photonic energy rippling all
around her there's a really important
thing that happens on Marvel's ship that
you all probably noticed in the theater
but maybe he didn't think too much about
at the time remember when she's standing
up starts glowing brighter and brighter
you see the lights dim all over the ship
the force fields go down a little bit
the energy handcuffs the other energy
base weapons and rifles the Creator
holding start to short out a little bit
you can kind of see where I'm going with
this Captain Marvel is absorbing all
that energy to power herself up to
binary level so when Nick Fury says you
know you're glowing right that's her
like right below binary level like she's
right at the line there
she doesn't really go full binary until
she stops all those missiles when she's
going back up to stop Ronan's at
HAC so she absorbs a lot of the energy
from one of those missiles throws one of
them back into the others then blows
those up she continues into outer space
blows up Ronin as smaller ships by
blasting them then flies through the
bigger ships like a hot knife through
butter
that's full power captain marvel at
binary level that's also when she's
powerful enough to be in the vacuum of
space without a helmet like you see her
just sitting there floating around like
Superman
so really importantly the movie did not
do though is they didn't take the time
to actually explain how that works like
you just wanted to show you really cool
action scene there's other characters
that actually asked her about it like
what's going on here she's like I'll
explain how it works later the really
important way they balance her character
out to keep her from just completely
side railing the story by being way too
powerful is that she could only stay at
that binary level so long as she
continues to absorb more energy the
reason why this scene of her going
binary goes on for so long is because
these smaller ships of Ronan's that
she's blowing up are also blasting her
with their energy weapons she's
absorbing that it continues to make her
more and more powerful so like she has
her own version of the Captain America I
could do this all day moment where she
pounds her fists in that comic book pose
when she's standing in front of Ronan in
front of his ship there if you really
got down to it she could only do that
all day if she just continued to absorb
energy it's the same thing with a lot of
the other Avengers - except for the
whole the way the Hulk's power works is
kind of an inverse of the way that
Captain Marvel and Thor work because
they can get tired like normal people if
they expend enough energy the whole kind
of goes in Reverse with that he just
keeps getting madder and madder stronger
and stronger she also uses her photonic
energy to fly I think based on just what
they presented in the movie because she
falls for a little while until she sort
of figures it out is that she needs to
at least have a minimum amount of energy
in order to achieve flight like if her
reserves are drained too low she might
be stuck huffing around like everyone
else but at base level she still has
greatly enhanced strength and durability
so just like Thor she could take a punch
or two from the Hulk but a really great
comparison to make to Captain Marvel in
the Captain Marvel movie and Thor and
Thor Ragnarok is that they both have
like their base levels then when Thor is
crackling with energy fighting on the
Rainbow Bridge that's sort of like his
version of Super Saiyan and Captain
Marvel has her own version of Super
Saiyan they can only maintain that for a
certain amount of time until they just
wear down
use too much energy but the difference
with Thor is that you can wear him down
just like a normal person if you keep
him fighting long enough it just takes
way way longer because he's super super
strong but unlike Captain Marvel he
doesn't run out of energy he can just
keep calling lightning as much as he
wants but his physical body will just
wear down and to the point where he
can't fight anymore
it's not like he could run out of
lightning whereas Captain Marvel most
definitely can run out of photonic
energy but even when she's running on
fumes she's still super powerful super
durable so hopefully that explains on a
story level how they're handling her
character especially the end of the
movie because I saw so many questions
about you know what's gonna happen with
her stories in the future if she's so
powerful what possible threat could
there be for someone like that so you
just have to remember that she's not
always that powerful but if you have any
other big questions about the mechanics
of everything or what was going on
during the Captain Marvel movie just
leave questions in the comments below
I'll be doing more Avengers ingame
videos soon many thanks to the Marvel
future fight people click here for my
Captain Marvel post-credit scene video
and click here for all my Captain Marvel
movie Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]